Hi, my name is Travis Fry Singinger. I'm
the technical director of AI ETHLite and
I'm here to talk to you about the
coherency trap or why prompting feels
like magic but
isn't. This is a top-down talk focused
on how I understand LLM. It's about
explaining why LLM work so well when we
know they're not intelligent and they
lack intent or desire. It's very much a
story about chasing a feeling across
experiments, analysis, and finally
formulating a
theory. Let's step back to November
2022. Uh
GPT3.5 was released. A lot of hype in
the news about it. Uh and I promptly
went to go check it out. I'm sure like a
lot of us did. I was very quickly
disappointed. While it had shown some
advancements in certain areas like it
could help me improve an email and do
other things that I wasn't used to doing
with a chatbot. My experience with chat
bots have been kind of very customer
support type of focused activities. Uh
it was very brittle in its
understanding. Uh it surface level
fluency often collapsed at edge cases.
It had prompt sensitivity, so small
wording changes, obviously context
limits, and overall felt very hyped up,
right?
Overhyped. Uh, and then GPT4 came out
not much later. I think it was about
January of
2023. Uh, and you know, it was a very
uncanny moment. My brain started to
tingle as the words seemed to align
effortlessly on the screen. So, what
happened here? You know, I wasn't alone.
other folks like Microsoft uh research
published a paper sparks of artificial
general intelligence early experiments
with
GPT4 Ethan Mollik uh a pretty well-known
academic in this space uh started
conducting some more research I think
doing a little writing as well around
this uh and overall you know there was
there was something we were all noticing
right like it had surpassed anything
we'd known before uh just that
experience that interaction that
perceived level of utility was something
that we hadn't uh encountered at least I
hadn't encountered in my experiences
with
AI something had fundamentally shifted
uh specifically you know when output
felt like understanding it it's the
moment when AI transcends mere text
generation and displays something eerily
similar to
comprehension hence the Microsoft paper
on AGI I didn't feel that that was
adequately capturing what I was feeling
I felt there was a space in between
these really like very dumb chat bots to
AGI. Um, and I wanted to explore that a
little bit more. So, what did I do?
Well, I do what I do. I started doing
experiments. I'm a bit of an engineer
and a scientist. Um, you know, just as
comfortable writing some research papers
as I am like producing production code.
Uh, so I started digging to
understand. Where did I start? Not where
I would have expected. I started with a
live stream. uh mainly because it was a
low friction way. My colleague I was
talking to about the idea. I'd
recommended it. She had known others
that you know gotten traction with this
not specifically around AI but just
thought
leadership. So I fired up the YouTube
stream and started working with chat GPT
in a live scenario. Uh I did paired
programming. Uh I called it chat
assisted programming, others called it
chat oriented programming. Uh and
finally we know it is vibe coding today.
Uh it was a really interesting
experience because it took a lot of
effort to get just a few hundred lines
of producible uh usable code out of the
system right wasn't a great experience I
was building in public you know a lot of
nerves but ultimately it did balloon
into something bigger these weren't just
hacks these were prototypes for what AI
pair programming would become and I
still use a lot of that same technique
today uh in tools like cursor or wind
surf uh at the end of the day I
developed one really useful utility
ility called Webcat. It was a Python
Azure function that would scrape a web
page and bring back the contents for me.
Why was this super useful? Well, and
then paired with a custom GPT. Why was
this super useful? Because the early
chat GPT4 didn't have internet access. I
was often copying web pages in trying to
chat with him, explore ideas. While, you
know, it had this vast corpus of
knowledge, it just wasn't very useful
for the things I was trying to solve.
So, I made a utility to try and address
that.
which then led on to, you know, deeper
collaborative experiments. Uh, I ended
up building my blog,
AIBuddy.software. Go check it out if
you're interested. Uh, it's been running
for a little over a year, probably about
a year and four months now. Uh, and the
idea was, can I work with AI to build
this? Not that AI is super smart and
it's going to give me all the answers,
but, you know, kind of lean into this
collaborative essence uh, that I was
feeling along the way here.
So I let it pick the platform using
Ghost. Uh I had a server to put it on
already. You know I didn't I had some
weird constraints. I didn't want to use
like medium or other you know public
services. I wanted to keep this low
cost. So it gave me the instructions. I
followed them. We together the AI and
myself built a template you know that
fit the need and we started live
streaming. Uh again I say we uh I
started live streaming while working
with chat GPT. uh I was using WebCAT to
pull in you know article snippets to
talk about those in relation to ideas
and have it help me build a blog around
various concepts and it's worked
successfully you know I I have a very um
I think you know pretty well trafficked
uh thought leadership blog uh so I would
say that's been awesome and
successful which led me on to you know
thinking about how can I make a bigger
project it's good it's kind of good for
code At this point, it's definitely good
at content generation. Uh, what else can
I do? Can I make music? Now, I do have a
background in music. Uh, I'm a trained
pianist, so I I understand music theory
and other things. Uh, but I wanted to
produce a whole concept album. You know,
I figured, hey, my cat, I like my cat.
Um, I like metal. Can I make a feline
metal album? Uh, let's call it Mr.
Fluff's Reign of Tiny Terror. And the
goal was just to produce something fun
and silly. Use multiple tools. Use chat
GPT for the lyrics and the music
composition. Uh image editing as well.
Could I keep images relatively
consistent across interactions? Uh this
was the first time that you could
actually work with the J Chat GPT image
generation and ask it to refine. Prior
to that, it been a lot like a slot
machine. So, you know, there's new uh
creative partnering prospects here. So,
I wanted to lean into those and
understand them. And I I thought I'd
done everything to handicap this
process, right? Like it's it's cat
metal. Like who's going to be in cat
metal? It's AI generated. Like am I
going to be able to produce anything of
value or is this going to just be AI
slop? Well, much to my surprise, I just
uploaded the videos to YouTube. Didn't
let anyone know they were out there. And
within a month, I had over 3,000 views,
which, you know, for feline cat metal AI
generated stuff seems pretty impressive.
And what's even more impressive is I had
a lot of likes. I had a lot of positive
comments. I clearly was able to create
something outside of just my own
capabilities uh in assistance with AI
that was of value and people recognize
the value. So this got me thinking, huh,
okay, so it's working across a variety
of things. I can create a single
coherent concept. Uh maybe there's
there's something here. maybe I need to
start looking for
um other
behaviors. So I decided, hey, you know,
decision intelligence is a thing. It
exists within the traditional or tread
AI space. It's very useful for
understanding how to work with AI
systems where, you know, you need to
make decisions. And I'm like, hey, I'm
an engineer. I've been doing pair
programming since the early 2000s. Like,
you know, maybe these two things are
kind of the secret sauce. So, let me go
go looking there. I didn't know what
else to look for either.
They figure like a good jumping off
point. Uh, can I could I go look for
elements of decision intelligence and
could I go look for elements of pairing
behavior? Well, sure. I broke out the
vibe coding skills and built an analysis
tool. I downloaded my chat GPT history
and I started building a tool to pull
out each chat history, run it through
with a prompt to look for qualitative
and quantitative metrics around decision
intelligence, pairing behaviors. Um, you
know, was there this thing happening?
You know, was there a concept in there
that I could name? Um, or was it just
kind of me going, ah, yes, of course.
You know, I'm doing these things. I know
about them. Now, I did end up writing a
research paper on this. I wrote a 21page
case study uh that outlines the
technique um that outlines the prompts
that outlines you know the things I was
looking for. It's all there on my AI
buddy site um slashpapers if you're
interested. Uh but it was a really neat
experience. It really allowed me to kind
of bridge the the kind of you know
business world with the academic world
again. So what did I pull out? I pulled
out something I'm calling the AI
decision loop. I feel like, you know, at
the initial stage, it was very academic.
I was trying to make sure I checked all
the boxes and had all these delineated
phases. I would probably roll roll it
into a four-step process, which we'll
talk about on the next slide. But the
idea is that you frame the problem,
right? You come with the problem in the
context. Think of this as prompt
engineering. It's the one place where I
guess the hype makes sense. Uh then
you're going to generate some outputs,
maybe one, maybe many, depends on what
your prompt is.
And here's where most people I think
fall off. They don't really engage with
the output. They kind of take it and
carry
on. But you really need to judge. You
need to evaluate the quality and the
fit. You know, if you extra level vig ri
v ri v ri v ri v ri v ri v ri v ri v ri
v ri vigor you can think about
validating it. Maybe there's some
external requirements you need to go
through and
fine-t kind of be asking it questions.
Validate would be some external
validation and then iterate. Right? This
isn't a once- off prompt and accept type
scenario. What did I get right? What did
I get wrong? What can you do to improve
that experience? Um so that it starts
getting more towards what you're looking
for, you know, and then start it again.
Frame it again. Generate, judge,
validate, iterate, and keep going
through that
cycle. I said there's a less academic
version. I would like to think of this
as kind of the nudge and iterate uh
framework. So frame, generate, judge,
iterate. frame it up, generate some
responses, evaluate those responses, and
continue to prompt and nudge the model
in such that it produces more and more
reliable outputs. This is kind of what I
found at the heart of my reliable
interactions. Not every interaction
follow this. Not every interaction was
good. But when I did and I followed this
frame, generate judge, iterate
framework, I tended to have much better
uh
outcomes. So that's all good. I've got a
me mechanic. I've done some exper
experimenting, but it still didn't
explain why these things weren't uh you
know um intelligent. So I did some more
thinking. I was like okay you know I've
done a lot of natural language
processing work. Coherency is a concept
that sits there starts to feel like it
makes more sense. some work uh by
anthropic had come out around feature
superp position and concept circuits
along with a lot of other research I was
reading at the time and I was like hm
you know maybe this is a a coherence
theory you know what would that look
like how would I actually explain what's
happening inside the machine to achieve
these outcomes if it's not
thinking and I think the idea here is
that you know it's coherence is a system
property it's not a cognitive one it's a
precog cognitive one. It's the it's the
infrastructure that thought navigates.
My thoughts particularly I'm giving it
to the infrastructure of the
machine. So what is coherence? Let's
talk about that briefly. Um so for me
coherence has you know four key
properties. It's relevant. It means the
model's output feels topical, connected
and purposeful to the
conversation. It's consistent. the model
maintains a you know a singular tone
terminology and structure across
multiple turns. So if I'm like the 10th
time I'm having response with the
chatbot it still knows that MCP is model
context protocol. It's not something
else. Uh and I think the single most
important property of this is stability
right the model's uh able to withstand
uh pressure. So you can question it
about its outcome or you know give it a
competing theory or you know whatever
you're going to do to kind of judge
what's happening there. It doesn't fall
down. It doesn't collapse under that
interrogation. It maybe firms up or
course corrects. I feel that's a lot of
what was missing from the chat 3.5 GPT
3.5 days and other earlier models. Uh
and most intriguingly it's an emergent
property. uh we see this specifically an
example would be GPT40 has never been
trained to detect swine disease. Uh yet
it can diagnose that through what I'm
calling coherent pattern alignment. We
see the same thing with certain types of
cancer diagnosis diagnosis. It's able to
pick up that pattern before we can even
see that there's a pattern there um to
be
detected. So how does this operate? So
talking about coherence in the machine,
let's get into some of the mechanics
here. Um so typically we think of neural
networks as storing uh a concept in a
single neuron. So a neuron holds on to
cat and it knows that when it encounters
a cat that's the neuron that's supposed
to light
up. Well, some research by enthropic is
saying that in these large language
models that's not exactly the case.
There's something called superposition
that allows the network to represent
these complex ideas with fewer
parameters kind of packing more nuance
into the same space and as the context
accumulates the network teases apart the
relevant meaning and collapses that
ambiguity into a coherent output. So cat
for example it might store feline pet
animal right across a few different
neurons and those neurons could also
store the essence of a dog canine pet
animal and so forth like an idea isn't
distributed just across a set of neurons
a set of neurons can hold multiple ideas
as
well. So meaning isn't retrieved, it's
constructed on demand from distributed
sparks of possibility. Okay, think of it
this way. Your prompt is a force vector.
Prompts act with a directional force in
the highdimensional latent space that a
AI model operates in. Each prompt sets a
specific direction which the AI then
aligns patterns to. So the concept of a
cat or a dog kind of wears grooves in
that latent space and it'll generally
follow that space. Uh anthropics tracing
thoughts. Uh Ethan Mollik's got some
thoughts here. Stanford CRFM uh also has
some thoughts here. There's a lot of
research to kind of I think justify this
perspective that um you know prompts or
force vectors navigating latent space.
Okay, so if they're force vectors
navigating latent space, how does that
actually happen? Well, when you prompt a
model, you're going to give it some
external context. You're going to give
it the prompt, the question, the thing
you're trying to figure out. Uh and it's
going to go into the latent space. So
let's say we got storytelling and
freedom here. You know, these are
conceptual clouds. They're going to
light up around that idea at execution,
at inference
time. So, you know, some parts of the
model are better at these things.
Storytelling is obviously encoded in one
region, freedom in another. Uh, you
know, maybe everything it knows about
household pets in a in a third. Um, and
they only light up when they're needed.
Um, so they're not pre-wired. They
emerge during training, but these
specialized patterns uh activate when
the context calls for them. So let's say
storytelling and pets. Now, it's not
going to always over cross over on the
same like set of concepts, right? Like
maybe I'm I'm a little more detailed
about the type of pet. Maybe it's a bird
and I'm telling a lot of detail about
the bird. Um, but I still want it to
tell me a short story. So it's going to
merge those two concepts into a new
idea. That force vector is going to
cause something new to emerge based on
the subn networks that light
up not just retained compressed
information. So what does this lead to?
Well, this leads to a new kind of
utility. Uh most theories focus on
compression, how efficient models store
and retrieve knowledge. But I think the
real value of LMS is in their ability to
recreate uh the essence of an idea. to
take multiple essences and to create
something
new. Uh so this is why when they
hallucinate it still feels correct.
They're they're creating a compelling
pattern. They're not fact-checking.
They're not being intelligent. But that
essence reconstruction. There's a lot of
utility in there. So what does this mean
from an engineering standpoint? Well, we
got to frame systems as coherent, not
intelligent. And when we do that, we
start to see things slightly
differently.
The first thing that we're going to see
differently here is that hallucinations
are an indicator of coherence. It will
fill in the gaps if you don't give it
enough information not to. Um, you know,
models hallucinate generally hallucinate
on the same type of prompt in
predictable ways following an internal
logic and coherency vectors. Uh, I see
it as a system feature. It's kind of an
emergent behavior of this emergent
behavior. Uh, less a bug of the system.
It's trying to complete the pattern.
How do we fix that? Well, we all know
rag, right? Retrieval, augmented
generation. So, we think about those rag
fragments as factual anchors, right? And
if they get large enough, there's enough
contextual gravity there. It's going to
really pull that concept in the right
direction. Think of it as the structural
scaffolding that shapes how coherency
unfolds. It's the it's the
infrastructure for thought. I take my
thought, my uh intent, and I give it to
the machine to navigate that latent
space with
Another way to think about this is my
three layer model. We've got layer one,
the latent space. That's the internal
model structure, concepts, weights,
activations. It's just sitting there.
Layer two is the execution layer, the
tools, the APIs, and the retrieval
mechanisms. Its goal is to bring extra
context for layer 1. And layer three is
the conversational interface. That's
where the intent passes from me, the
thought passes from me to the machine.
uh there's grounding in human intent um
that need to come through for layers one
and two to be of value to be
actionable. So how do we actually build
for coherence not intelligence? Think of
prompting as interfaces. They're not
once off. They're a component in the
system.
uh you know rag to ground as coherency
anchors to steer the generation dense
relevant context works like gravity
pulling output towards a
reality design for emergence not control
it's not deterministic you know build
around that frame generate judge iterate
loop avoid fragile chains long reasoning
chains often break coherency keep
structured uh keep your chains modular
and reinforce the context at each point
and Watch for breakdowns in tone,
structure, flow. They're early signs
that the model's losing its grip on
context. It needs to be brought back.
Use that as a jumping inpoint to kind of
debug that part of the system. Maybe it
means adjusting your uh you know, chunk
size in your vector DB. Maybe it means
bringing in other tools outside of just
a vector database to help that
problem. So, in the end, I like to think
of LLMs as a highdimensional mirror.
We're not talking to a thinker. We're
standing in front of a mirror with
80,0001 dimensions. The machine doesn't
understand you. It resonates with you
through structure, not thought.
Sometimes what it reflects back is
sharper than what you gave it. LLMs are
not intelligent. They're coherent. And
that's their superpower. The magic
happens in the collaborative dance. So
stop chasing intelligence and start
designing for structured residents.